for more on this let's bring in Claudio
Rodriguez she serves on El Paso's city
council uh Claudia thanks so much for
being with us you heard Aisha's
reporting there
um Henry cuer is coming under Fire now
for lack of funding for the Border
crisis in the new Omnibus package but
it's close to 70 billion dollars that's
not peanuts
that is correct I mean the fact that we
have a tent city that's being built in
El Paso a shelter a huge shelter
um to house all these migrants you know
is that going to be the solution moving
forward are we going to be funding
shelters are we going to be in the
business is that going to be one of our
new operational costs right here in the
city of El Paso where we are now going
to be housing migrants but then what
what comes after that that is the
question that is why now I am calling on
the President Biden to come to El Paso
and look at our city and tell us what
the solution moving forward is because
this right here is unsustainable
um I don't see this really going
anywhere other than just more shelter
more shelter more shelter but really
it's not securing our border
talk to me about
um these sort of Staggering stats of Fox
News projects that when title 42 is
lifted
um it means we're going to see about 14
000 people crossing the border illegally
per day that's up to 420 000 per month
5.1 million
per year sometimes it's hard for us to
wrap our heads around numbers like this
so talk to us about what those stats
look like on the ground for your city
I mean El Paso is a city that we have
about 600 000 people that's our
population here so we're going to be
seeing our population according to your
stocks every month and so to me that's a
very unsustainable
um there needs to be better policy the
the federal government needs to
legislate you know we have our Texas DPS
we have our Texas National Guard
securing our border right now we're
doing it for Public Safety we're trying
to push everybody towards a Port of
Entry so that people can come in even if
they're claiming Asylum through a port
of entry and preventing them from
running across the freeway preventing
them from getting run over and killed I
mean it's it's a really
it's frightening what's happening in El
Paso not only for the community but
because we're not used to this even
though we are a border City we're not
used to this type of environment where
we just see people running across our
freeways and running into our backyards
it's very scary
um people are sleeping on the streets
you know it's completely out of the
normal and again there is no plan moving
forward and to see that the federal
government is just building another
intensity okay but then what what comes
after that are we just going to be
building intensity after Tent City and
we're just going to be housing them is
that going to be the new normal for us I
mean FEMA being you using FEMA as an
operational cost for this is also
unsustainable I mean FEMA can't even
we're supposed to be taking care of
hurricanes and tornado victims and our
homeless population but now we're using
them as an extension for the whole
migrant situation when the Biden
Administration
calls the relocation of three bus loads
of people to Washington DC shameful and
cruel as it did this week it sort of
underscores the broader point which is
that the immigration system at the
national level in this country is both
of those things because as you point out
when you allow people to come here to
the United States and yet states have
zero capacity to absorb them into
society
that is cruel and that is shameful
people end up on the streets people end
up starving people end up freezing
and to be fair with more cruel is the
fact that they're being bused to our
border right we have video of of the
Mexican federates that are that are
busting these migrants to our border
they're on on airplanes from Cancun to
Cuates and then they're being dropped
off at the border so I mean that to me
is very cruel where who's bringing these
people here under what expectations are
they coming here and why are we you know
we're bringing them in because we are
Humane but we don't have the resources
here in El Paso to be able to absorb
that many people nor does any other
Border City in the state of Texas have
those types of resources and mind you we
are the sixth largest city in the state
of Texas and we are the first largest
city on the border so if we can't do it
I can't imagine anybody else on the
border can do it either
uh councilwoman Claudia Rodriguez thanks
so much for taking time with us this
afternoon we appreciate it
thank you for having me I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis